[Music]
the movie review aggregation site rotten
tomatoes doesn't always give the most
accurate impression of a film's
uh you know quality for anybody
unfamiliar with the site if you are the
the idea is that all the reviews of a
film are compiled and categorized as
generally positive or generally negative
and then we're given a percentage score
so a movie with a positive percentage
above 60 is fresh
um ostensibly if the positive percentage
is higher 70 80 90. it's supposed to be
pretty good assurance that the film is
you know very high quality
the problem is that a film which most
critics found just mildly amusing might
end up with a 95 fresh score simply
because 95 of critics were mildly amused
by it so the 95 is a bit misleading in
that case as we tend to associate 95
with an a plus grade but the rod
tomatoes grading system in effect
makes it so that a whole bunch of c
minuses can add up to an a plus this is
how every marvel movie passes as
critically acclaimed for example
the other problem is that
film critics are some of the most
shameless and dishonest shills in media
which is really saying something so a
very good film that fails to pass the
woke litmus test may end up with a 30 or
40 percent
in those cases it can be enlightening as
people know to look at the audience
score and compare it because rotten
tomatoes also allows regular joes to
leave their reviews and their rating on
a one to five star scale
frequently movies that are panned for
political reasons will have a very
lopsided review ratio maybe because 30
from critics but at 90 from audiences
and if you see something like that you
know almost every time that the film is
probably pretty decent
sometimes it'll go the other way and a
film will have a 90 from critics and a
30 from audiences this usually means
that the movie is this kind of like
meandering pointless art house tripe
that critics pretended to like so they
would seem smart
all in all
a lot can be gleaned from a comparison
of the two percentages
so
what can we learn from this
as of last night my new film what is a
woman had earned a 97 score from the
audience with well over a thousand
reviews counted
which is a lot of reviews by the way
from from audiences so there are a lot
of big box office
films that uh don't get a thousand
reviews in the first week as we did 97
what score did it get from the critics
well n a not applicable there's no score
they just haven't reviewed it none of
them there's one critic review and it's
from christian toto who's a great
contributor for the daily wire
outside of that though the movie has
been completely and totally ignored by
the media
why haven't they watched it
it's not it's not that they're panning
it they're just not they're refusing to
watch it and why is it because they they
don't know about it or they don't have
time to watch it or just they don't
think it's very important or whatever
well they might be able to make that
claim
if not for the fact that we sent the
screener to media critics and many of
them responded
to the email that we sent them telling
us in so many words to go f ourselves
actually in those words exactly in some
cases so let me read through a few of
the responses that we got from film
critics
one says unsubscribe unsubscribe
unsubscribe unsubscribe unsubscribe
continuing infinity another one says
unsubscribe lose my email forget my name
uh another one says hard effing pass i
won't give that transphobic bigot a
platform on my site never email me again
another hard pass
another one says absolutely not he's a
bigot you should be ashamed for
associating with him
another one please remove it from remove
me from your mailing list i am not
interested in anything having to do with
matt walsh another one says big no
thanks
um
let's see yeah i'm not reviewing a film
by a bigot and if that's how who you
work with you can take me off your list
i won't be reviewing anything from you
another one says please don't send me
anything else from the daily wire i'm
not interested
and then we got a bunch of uh
uh this one was good okay here's one
says hi
trans woman here
just got your email inquiring if i
wanted to review your nazi transphobic
movie in the future please send requests
like requests like this to deesnuts
gmail.com now
i don't think this person realizes that
the last part of their email
in the first part
hi uh i'm a woman
send the request to these nuts
all right
um
and then another one says take me off
your list i'm not interested in covering
content from fear-mongering people whose
inquiries into gender and identity are
predicated on the basis of taking rights
away from people in at-risk communities
and spreading misinformation for the
sake of grabbing power and wielding it
against people
um and then a bunch of others i have no
interest in covering this film or
anything to do with matt walsh please
never email me again okay so you get the
idea
now
you may hear all that and think well of
course they responded that way
and in one sense you're right i mean of
course they did but let's not allow them
to hide behind the inevitability of
their own cowardice and intellectual
dishonesty as if they're drawn up by the
forces of fate and have no choice but to
act like a bunch of spineless little
blobfish
the fact is that film critics in mass
are declaring at the outset that they
simply will not even watch
one of the most talked about films of
the year so far one audiences are raving
about and which is indeed a legitimate
and well-made piece of work well made
thanks to our director and producer not
so much to me but it is well made
um it's not unprecedented for a film to
be blackballed to this extent but it is
unusual
because again usually what they'll do if
they don't like the movie for political
reasons is that they'll just pan it
and this reveals once again that
our cultural gatekeepers are totally
beholden to a certain ideological agenda
this doesn't just extend to the people
who create the culture the people who
make the film shows music etc it also
and especially extends the people who
decide which pieces of content in each
of those categories we ought to be
consuming and engaging with
the left's cultural institutional
domination works through multiple layers
okay they decide what's made
and if someone manages to make something
that they don't approve of then the
gatekeepers and media can step in to
make sure that nobody hears about it
the good news is that these gatekeepers
have become increasingly impotent as we
develop ways of getting around them and
one very effective way of getting around
them is to do exactly what we're doing
here at the daily wire build our own
institutions slowly but surely and
sustain it with the support from the
audience
rather than
making ourselves entirely beholden to
advertisers investors shareholders and
so on
and that's just another good reason to
go to what is a woman.com and subscribe
today if you haven't
one other point about the critical
reaction to the film or lack thereof
is that it perfectly illustrates the
point of the film itself the left is
terrified
of the movie of the question
of the approach we took
the truth that we brought to bear
see
if they thought that our film could be
easily debunked um then they'd watch it
and they'd debunk it
they love doing that
you know if they really thought it was a
bunch of transphobic nonsense as they
claim then they would watch it and they
would just they would
point out all of the nonsense in the
movie
if they really thought it was nothing
but a bunch of ignorant bigotry
they would delight in pointing out all
the ways that such is the case
they'd go through it with a fine-tooth
comb john oliver would do a whole show
dissecting it playing clips making
snarky comments
but he can't do that none of them can
because there's no rescuing the people
who made fools of themselves in the film
there's no defending gender ideology in
general
there's no way for them to answer the
question without destroying their own
world view in the process
now at some level they know that the
film is successful in debunking gender
ideology because at some level they know
that gender ideology is a flimsily
constructed tower of jenga blocks
wobbling in the breeze and ready to fall
over if just one block is removed and
with our film we're going for the block
away at the base of the tower the blocks
the other blocks are sitting on
which means that the tower is certain to
topple
the left doesn't want to be there to
watch it happen for fear that it will
fall directly on their heads so they
look the other way they run the other
direction they cover their eyes they
close their ears hope that eventually we
all get bored and stop talking about the
fact that their world view is incoherent
absurd and poisonous to civilization
but we're not going to stop
unfortunately for them
and i have to say i also enjoy the
filmmaking process so much that i don't
plan to stop doing that either it's
pretty fun
i'll give the critics uh many more
movies which i'm sure that they will
pretend don't exist
they can do that all they want
they're still i must say today canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated